trois candidats s'affrontent pour ce
second tour à voisins le bretonneux
la maire sortante alexandra rosetti est
arrivé en tête avec 47 72 % talonné par
la liste d'union de l'opposition
actuelle menée par olivier afonso avec
34 86 %
enfin la liste divers gauche mené par
bête respirera s'est maintenu également
avec 17,6 recul de 42% la commune et ses
onze 1426 habitants connaît un problème
de logement 6 590 logements ont
dernièrement été construit la ville a
tout de même perdu 1000 habitants 15 ans
en cause notamment le prix de
l'immobilier voisins le bretonneux doit
chercher à attirer de jeunes familles
un projet d'éco quartier est en cours
avec 500 logements et un jardin partagé
prévue pour 2022
à noter également le nombre de logements
sociaux la commune en comporte 18 5%
elle est en dessous des 25 % demandés
par l'état décide 2025
autre problématique d'urbanisme la
construction d'un troisième cimetière
le premier remplacement sélectionné au
square des 40 arpents a été contestés
par un collectif constitué spécialement
pour s'opposer à sa création
deux autres terrains sont à l'étude la
situation géographique de la ville en
porte de la vallée de chevreuse lui
causent des problèmes de circulation
elle est engorgé aux heures de pointe
chaque candidat proposé solutions
d'aménagement différentes pour régler ce
problème
une circulation dense qu'une association
de défense de la vie la peur de voir
amplifié par l'arrivée de la ligne 18 et
son nouveau quartier saint quentin est
enfin voisins le bretonneux n'est pas
épargné par la désertification médicale
les médecins présents actuellement sont
complets et approchent de la retraite un
projet de maisons fleuries
professionnels de santé est en cours des
généralistes et spécialistes sont
recherchés un enjeu dont l'importance
est accentuée avec la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus